[Music]
so here's a statement that won't blow
anyone's mind the scp foundation is
really really really weird and we're not
even talking about the actual anomalies
they contain sure this top secret
organization puts in the time and the
effort to make sure menaces to society
like the heart to destroy reptile the
scarlet king and even the horrifying bad
joke tomatoes stay behind lock and key
but sometimes you need to hold the
mirror up to yourself and see just what
the heck is going on i mean seriously
think about it this is an organization
that uses live human beings farmed from
death row as test subjects considering
how rarely the death penalty is actually
employed in the western world these days
you know some shady strings are being
pulled there and what about the o5
council the leaders of humanity's last
line of defense against anomalous chaos
and according to some accounts they're a
group of vain petty and morally bankrupt
individuals who regularly use anomalies
like scp-006 the fountain of youth for
their own personal benefit and don't
even get me started on the actual
scientists working under the
foundation's payroll that's when things
start getting even stranger of course
there's dr jack bright a man forever
changed by the chance interaction with
scp-963
an anomalous medallion and one of abel's
deadly blades now he's an immortal
weirdo whose equal parts brilliant and a
total nuisance so much so that there's
an entire dedicated list forbidding all
of his zanier antics then there's dr
alto clef don't even try to shake his
hand given how much this ex-goc wild
card loves using violence to solve his
problems you may draw back a stump he
specializes in reality warping anomalies
often wheeled to yooka-laylee because
he's just so darn quirky oh and he's
very likely the baby daddy to a teenage
nature sprite after a delilance with a
goddess or oh and um what about dr
charles ogden gears sure he may not look
that strange to the naked eye he's a man
so dull and humorous that grey is his
favorite color and he thinks sugar on
cornflakes is an act of unacceptable
decadence but he's got a whole lot of
strangeness under the hood like the fact
he's such an emotionally unavailable
father that his daughters across
dimensions have formed a splinter cell
of the serpent's hand where they work
under the collective pseudonym the black
queen just to spite him dr dan through
acts of sabotage was personally
responsible for the worst
scp-096 outbreak in foundation history
leading to the end of thousands of lives
just so he could receive clearance to
terminate the creature and he got that
clearance on the condition that the scp
foundation would be terminating him for
his crimes as soon as the goal is
achieved and then there's oh my gosh
did someone dress a dog up in scientist
clothes
oh my god that's the cutest thing i've
ever seen all this is just bright in my
day okay maybe i was being too harsh on
the foundation before who whose dog is
this excuse me sir that is extremely
inappropriate wait you can talk of
course i can talk you dolt i'm professor
kane pathos crow one of the scp
foundation's finest minds in the field
of advanced robotics and biochemistry i
have a level four clearance for 343's
sake i'm not some common bloody mutt oh
my apologies professor crow i wasn't
aware you were a
well a talking dog well yes i imagine
there's a lot you don't know about me
isn't there um
i'm a little embarrassed to admit it but
uh that's true professor crowe our data
on you and your work with the scp
foundation is a little sparse here take
these files they should give you a good
primer okay
i suppose we better take this from the
top then professor kane pathos crow
among a lineup of extremely eccentric
researchers somehow manages to rise to
the very top in terms of sheer
strangeness to get the most obvious fact
out of the way yes while he was once a
human an anomalous experiment did result
in him being turned into a labrador
retriever how did this happen you may
ask we have the same question sadly
professor crowe is incredibly reluctant
to share any details about this strange
and embarrassing incident so we're just
gonna have to accept it for what it is
and move on everyone ready
okay good despite his strange appearance
professor crowe is actually one of the
more scientifically qualified of the
foundation researchers it's no surprise
that because of this he has a relatively
close working relationship with dr gears
so much so that he still refers to gears
by his early foundation code name cog a
reference to both the legendary stern
doctor's initials and a pun on his
iconic surname during one incident dr
gears did tell professor crow to
terminate an anomaly that was for all
intents and purposes a human child if it
presented any difficulties this sours
the wholesomeness of that previous fact
so we'll swiftly move on once again dr
gears is just terrible with kids like a
lot of foundation researchers professor
crow was personally headhunted by the
scp foundation after his academic work
in the fields of advanced robotics and
biochemistry started turning heads this
was just for clarity's sake back before
professor crowe was turned into a
labrador professor crow spends most of
his time working in bio research area 12
where he studies a variety of anomalies
but his bookish nature also earned him
another interesting position he's the
scp foundation's chief librarian where
his encyclopedic knowledge of anomalous
technical literature has made him a
valuable asset in archiving and
organization this balances out some of
professor crowe's indiscretions it is
important to specify that professor
crowe is genuinely a well-liked figure
among his scp foundation co-workers
after all who wouldn't love to work with
an adorable dog in a lab coat and
glasses all day but it's also important
to note that he is also somewhat
mistaken prone with a number of these
mistakes putting him in the crosshairs
of his superiors professor crowe has
come close to outright termination
several times perhaps the most out of
any prominent researcher currently
working at the foundation however to
keep himself out of the same dead man
walking category that the thoroughly
unpleasant doctor dan currently finds
himself in professor crow has a few aces
up his sleeve firstly he's got friends
in the administrative department willing
to pull a few strings to keep him out of
harm's way hey maybe they're just very
ardent dog lovers up there the other
thing that's kept him from being turned
into an extremely overqualified chew toy
for scp-682
is the contents of his brilliant brain
on many of the occasions where the 05
council have considered terminating him
he's demonstrated the fact he possesses
vital and often irreplaceable knowledge
saving his furry skin a perfect example
of the kinds of strange scrapes that
professor crowe gets himself into is the
incident in 2009 where without even
realizing it he somehow traveled through
time and scared the living daylights out
of everyone the details are best
expressed here in professor crowe's own
dictated notes 1802 2009 in all my years
working here there have been few things
which have irritated me cause me
physical harm yes cause me undue stress
yes cause me innumerable amount of
mental distress yes but few things have
just irritated me time travel is one of
them i went to bed on the 15th of
january year 2009 at 1 30 am i woke up
on february 18th at 9 26 a.m of the same
year i hadn't moved i had only nine
hours of sleep and to me nothing had
happened then after a slightly confused
day amidst the many cries of i thought
you were dead among other things i might
add i discovered that i have been
missing for the past month and three
days in that time sofia had completely
taken over my duties though she had
halted all of my personal experiments
and was trying her utmost to relocate me
while keeping my disappearance from the
higher-ups apparently
expunged leaving me to sleep in a small
self-contained bubble of data expunged
and making at least data expunged which
was eventually shed by data expunged and
sending me back to this phase of space
and time needless to say i was slightly
irritated to say the least
2402 2009.
it had me in quarantine for nearly the
past week observing me and running tests
to see if they can find any sort of
strange abnormalities with my physiology
my behavior my anything if i had one
more hand shoved up my nether regions or
i'm forced to look at one more bloody
inkblot i'm going to flip out and go
rabid i'll say they'll stop the
quarantine soon and sofia says the
higher-ups still haven't caught on to
anything i suppose i'm lucky in that
count normally the only time they
quarantine something is when it's too
dead to be any sort of immediate
security hazard still i guess i can see
where they're coming from if it were my
decision i'd probably force a quarantine
too and probably for longer at least
they had the decency to give me my
clothes my pda and someone to dictate to
1203 2009 i'm still here and i hate it
day in day out it's the same thing get
up eat exercise and simple observation
until lunch then more observation until
dinner then lights out not allowed
anything other than the things i already
have and even then i only got those
because sophia felt bad for me i'm only
allowed to use them every day for an
hour at most otherwise they're also in
observational storage all this wasted
time that i could have been doing
something constructive something useful
something interesting but no i'm stuck
here because of a wry twist of fate
forcing me into this monotonous hell
they keep telling me i'll be let out
soon liars oh 505 2009 they've seen fit
to release me i almost thought i was
going to die in there still it almost
seems strange to be out and about again
but i do appreciate being back in my own
quarters my own clothes and my beloved
walker back by my side sofia has taken
good care of the facility while i was
gone i think i might actually leave that
to her while i keep to my experiments
she seems to enjoy the great deal suits
her analytical mind
all of my personal experiments are still
waiting for me with the exception of the
zero four zero test logs they simply
haven't posted their findings yet
stating that they needed my approval
first so i'll have to pour through those
the first chance i get i'm interested in
the progress she may have made still
there is a good deal of work to be done
and i am more than ready enough to take
it on after all i have to make up for
lost time don't i it's clear that life
isn't easy for poor professor crow much
like dr bright after experiencing the
mysterious event that turned him into a
dog professor crow is both a researcher
and an anomaly and unlike the
superficially subtle presentation of dr
bright's anomalous nature it's hard to
hide the strangeness of a talking dog in
human clothes this bizarre interstitial
zone he occupies forces the foundation
to keep him on an extremely short leash
no pun intended seriously professor it
wasn't intended i swear anyway the point
is professor crowe isn't allowed to
clock off at the end of the workday like
his fellow researchers do he's forced to
remain on site almost never appearing in
public if the professor wasn't the kind
of person who could easily get lost in
his work a situation like this would
probably drive him insane speaking of
you're probably wondering by this point
other than being the cutest researcher
at the foundation
sorry dr cleffy you're special in your
own way we promise what kind of work is
professor kane pathos crow actually
known for around here professor crowe's
most notable body of work is largely
based on an opinion that's pretty
controversial to hold around the scp
foundation he believes that they should
be actively utilizing anomalies that
aren't dangerous in order to further
their collective goals an excellent
example of this is the cordial
relationship he has with scp-040
also known as evolution's child she's a
powerful reality warper who is able to
synthesize new anomalous life from
pre-existing living creatures professor
crowe who refers to her as emma in his
personal writings was initially training
her to do this with scp-148
the infamous telekill alloy however he
also filed a formal request to go
further saying i think it's about time
we started trying to utilize 040's
abilities or at the very least allowing
her to use them enough to actually learn
how to control them she will not be able
to rely on the scp-148 hair pieces
forever we theorize that as she gets
older her powers will increase
exponentially possibly to the point
where her unconscious telepathy cannot
be contained he also somewhat infamously
went ham with a series of experiments
using scp-158
a frightening anomalous device known as
the soul extractor which contrary to its
name professor crowe also realized could
place removed souls into other objects
or creatures this led to the creation of
a being that crow dubbed zero because it
was subject zero in his experiments to
create a composite soul using scp-158
he spoke of this subject somewhat
creepily in his notes zero would make an
excellent candidate for my assistant it
respects and admires me for its creation
much as a child would an endearing
father figure i have assured it that it
would be treated well and that i would
give it a host to the best of my ability
to create all that it asks of me is that
it be given a name other than zero a
name not a number i told it to give
itself a name to christen itself
whatever it so wishes it told me it
would have to think about it like a lot
of strange and fascinating figures
everything you learn about professor
kane pathos crow seems to raise new
questions is crow just a mad scientist
without a cause eager to perform bizarre
experiments for their own sake well not
quite the sum total of all professor
crowe's work is project olympia a topic
that probably deserves a whole video in
its own right and do sound off in the
comments if you'd like to hear more
about the deranged frankenstein project
that professor crowe has devoted his
life to you see project olympia is
crow's baby and also his attempt to play
god through combining a variety of
different anomalies including all the
ones we've mentioned here and several
others he would hope to create an
entirely artificial living thing that
would serve the interests of the scp
foundation how exactly this would be
beneficial to the scp foundation is
admittedly a little confusing but seeing
this goal through to its conclusion has
become an all-consuming obsession for
professor crow he's performed countless
experiments with a huge catalog of
anomalies under the project olympia
umbrella he's written reams upon reams
of notes and logs on the subject and
produced a huge number of prototypes
he's also used project olympia as a
pretense to remove even more souls using
scp-158
because that just appears to be a
strange obsession of his doesn't it
incidentally we aren't the only ones
confused about the exact purpose and
value of project olympia when members of
the o5 council finally got a proper look
at professor crowe's work with the
project they released the following
statement all activity related to
project olympia has been discontinued
overwatch command has deemed it to be a
gross waste of resources and permanently
remove support for the project with
personnel assigned to work with it being
moved to alternative sites a hearing is
to be held with the project
administrators to determine how the
project was able to continue as long as
it did despite the lack of any concrete
results prototypes and other equipment
have been slated to be decommissioned
professor crowe took this news about as
well as you could expect but in the end
he always finds a way to wriggle out and
continue doing whatever he wants to do
because that's what professor kane
pathos crow is all about he's living
proof that sometimes he just can't keep
a good dog down now go check out scp
immortal dr bright explained and dr
cleff scp foundation researcher for more
explainers of the scp foundation's most
eccentric researchers